très bien nantis portrait chinois
eric nous si vous étiez une injure vous
soyez quelle injure connard une maladie
une maladie orpheline
quitte à être malade autant que ce soit
tout seul une perversion une perversion
la fidélité une trahison trahison la
vieillesse une arme le silence un
supplice l'adolescence un poison le
champagne une fan
une panne de magnétoscope
quand on enregistre un film qui ne passe
qu'une fois qu'on a attendu un dictateur
un nouveau né si vous étiez une torture
bon soyons littéraire les la lecture des
oeuvres complètes de christine angot ou
là une mort l'ivresse pourrait très gros
mort une plaie dans une plaie d'argent
l'histoire de banque j'ai publié chez
fayard mais la maison